here's a stoplight coming up but instead
of going up the stoplight I'm gonna cut
through this little restaurant parking
lot and beat the system we're [ __ ]
you know that right oh yeah yeah like we
located the street light well I watch
wait what did you watch any of the Black
History Month specials as a kid see
these are the things that they need to
teach us about a little bit harder a
little bit longer a little bit stronger
a little bit louder mm I feel like I
only know like two black inventors that
we're talking about the same way that
like Edison and Einstein were talked
about now I have a feeling you're about
to drop a list on me I think I didn't
know that we're invented by black people
I know for sure this was invented by a
black man I don't know why I remember
that I saw know what I make me happy
black guy this is a like a microphone a
milky but more specifically it looks
like something like a sexy chest thing I
might sing into okay I'm gonna go with
white no black white first black person
this I believe is made by a white guy
will forward those those were white
dudes and I'm gonna go white dude white
man we assess that right yeah and let
this is a trick how long were we [ __ ]
US history American public school
teaches you that
anything I did not like my first
instinct was to go straight to my phone
yes I got have to buy a calendar this
weekend too
okay so I literally just left the shoot
and I'm already breaking the rules
because I need to vlog and I need my
phone to blog so it's gonna be tough
maybe a little tougher than I thought
damn near [ __ ] everything that's like
necessary for living just like a basic
American life wasn't anybody my person
so essentially I broke in every single
rule because everything around me what's
enough to hire a [ __ ] winner the
first thing I did as soon as I left here
as I went and I got some food out of the
canteen did you guys know potato chips
were invented by a black person see
education Wow
what can I eat them healthy [ __ ] [ __ ]
rabbit food I was supposed to meet up
with a friend so I went to a coffee shop
and then my friend got mad at me because
in my life I had my laptop but I didn't
be using my laptop I totally broke all
the rules
I brought my laptop with me oh man
immediately we went home and the first
thing I did when I walked into my house
was I said Alexa turn on everything it's
just automatic Alexa turn off everything
well it's only 6:45 and it is dark in
here because I realized that I had a
candle but no matches
so I'm sitting in this over and of
course I am running late because my
alarm didn't go off and I have now
definitely become that friend who's an
hour and a half late because you know I
didn't get that code okay I realize I'm
not supposed to drive but I woke up late
this morning and I forgot that I hadn't
came in to do my taxes oh I decided to
take the street than these only stop
signs instead of going on Sunset
Boulevard is down there with all the
streetlights I'm doing stop signs
technically I'm breaking new rules so me
being in light right now I technically
start the music
listen to music and the microphone on
this phone I'm pretty much breaking
about like five rules now I'm in the
elevator
I don't like going up ten flights of
steps so now just I'm trying to deal
with it for me like every time I got on
the stairs or like past a stoplight or
whatever I it became like a fun fact in
my head that I would like share it with
whoever's with Ian did you know that
stoplights were invented by a black man
no I had no idea and also the thing that
they like go around that I learned was
that I can use other people's things so
like instead of me driving I made my
boyfriend drive do you think I can oh
boy is that some white people [ __ ]
really difficult living without
refrigerated items
[Music]
okay yeah if I told you microphones were
invented by a black man would you
believe me sure did you also know
lightbulbs invented by a black person
didn't know that but here's the thing as
I figured here's where I'm doing okay is
that normally you would use microphones
to record a podcast we're gonna
microphone in our phone but we're gonna
use our phone microphone so you're not
like microphone listen this is a very
hard video okay I do a podcast if we
don't use a microphone thank you for
inventing it thank you
look at you cheating what black
invention black invention
yes I'm at work I have to use my
computer at work
oh boy soliciting that it's impossible
to go as a bring the water ID without
okay so we're rounding out day three
here I think the hardest part of this
experience has definitely been the no
computer aspect and I now know that I
have dr. mark seem to think for that and
I wish I would have learned that earlier
imagine how far worse we would be
without these things you know I mean I
had take up for three days at first I
was like man I feel guilty that I didn't
know all this [ __ ] and it's not so much
that I feels guilty that I didn't know
about this [ __ ] it's more than I feel
guilty that I still live in a society
that doesn't recognize this kind of
stuff as important as white inventors
and that's what made me be like damn
okay I have some work to do
[Music]